thank you for being here day krista tell
me about your background and what
brought you to Microsoft research so I
came to Microsoft research back in 2006
after I finished my PhD in computer
science at Columbia and I came to
Microsoft research really because it was
it's really the top place to work for
computer science PhDs in industry the
people here are amazing problems amazing
and just a really fantastic place to
work so I wanted to come here to really
work on you know a set of problems and
have freedom and research and and to
work with the people that were here our
quantum computers did they exist today
are they mostly theoretical so we have
seen in the newspaper
quantum computers exist we've seen a
company from Canada d-wave claimed to
have a quantum computer I would say that
in fact we have quantum devices that
exist and we don't yet have what what
what I call a universal quantum computer
what we call in the field a universal
quantum computer in existence a quantum
computer that could perform any quantum
algorithm that we give it that doesn't
exist yet today what are some of the
challenges that you have as a computer
scientist with the universal quantum
computers not existing and what you have
to do in the mean time as the computer
scientists we're faced with the
challenge of actually building out the
whole system in terms of the interaction
between the classical computer that
controls the quantum computer the
language that needs to describe that
that has to take into account both the
classical instruction set and the
quantum instruction set you know how do
those systems interact so in computer
science we're really thinking about
building out the whole compiler and
understanding how those controls how the
feedback loops work how do we control
the quantum computer the universal issue
is really we have to be able to take any
quantum algorithm any any quantum
circuit that we program we need to be
able to run on the quantum device on the
quantum computer eventually Universal
quantum computer and that's where
building
quit our software architecture is really
key having a complete solid design flow
that will allow this mapping in an
automated fashion in an efficient
fashion is it has a great set of
challenges along that design flow and
that fun set of problems for computer
scientists so with the digital computer
I can look and see if I'm at a 1 or a 0
can you look at the state on a quantum
computer because looking at the state I
mean that's sir one of the problems
isn't it right so you so you can look at
the state but there are consequences so
naturally in a quantum computer it wants
to remain you know the qubits want to be
in their vacuum they want to be isolated
from the environment the more interacts
with the environment the more it
undergoes a process which we called
decoherence and decoherence essentially
means that the quantum system collapses
back to a classical system so instead of
being on this dimmer the dimmer will
flip to either on or off if I open the
box and look at the system if I measure
the system it's what we say so as soon
as I measure I'm back to just a
classical 0 or 1 essentially so so you
can look at the system with consequences
and so essentially in quantum algorithms
when we compute on a quantum computer we
will try to you know avoid what we want
to do is allow the quantum computer to
get into a state to - you know transform
into a state where when we look at it
it's in the state we need it's already
in the answer state essentially so in
1983 Hines pizzelles wrote about how
computers were then getting to the size
where a high-energy charged particle
from like natural radiation or a cosmic
ray could cause soft errors it could go
through a piece of silicon and flip a 1
to 0 and cause some problems is that
kind of problem exacerbated at the
quantum level what you're referring to
is a knows process and error process and
in classical digital computers we have
this problem at some levels but it's
they're pretty robust
and we don't have to worry about this
too much in a quantum computer that's
not the case first these systems sit at
extremely low temperatures in most cases
there are some qubit devices that might
sit at higher temperatures but most are
sitting at something like 20 millikelvin
coldest place in the universe they say
is in a dilution refrigerator which is
where our qubits sets so there were the
reason we're trying to isolate it from
noise exactly what you're talking about
noise is a huge problem and we have to
do a lot in quantum computing to
overcome that and what I mean by a lot
is we need software essentially kind of
a software error correction level so we
we take advantage of mathematical models
you know redundancy things things like
redundancy error correcting codes other
things where we'll use multiple physical
qubits to represent one logical qubit so
that if errors occur on the physical
qubits you know maybe we can still get
away with a clean logical qubit so we
have to have a lot of additional
resources that we use to protect against
this these noise processes yeah which
are a big problem can you explain what a
qubit is for those of us who are more
familiar with Qbert yes so a qubit is
our analog to a classical bit so qubit
stands for quantum bit and it's no
longer just binary the qubit is a you
can view it you know mathematically we
view it as a vector a complex vector so
if you just think of a two-dimensional
vector you have two entries in the
vector one represents the amplitude on
the zero state the other represents the
amplitude on the one state and we have a
superposition between 0 & 1 for qubit
it's not just on or off it can be
anywhere in between and so what this
means is these values for the qubit they
can be you know you can be partly on on
the 0 side partly on the one side you
can be equally in equal superposition so
I'm halfway between 0 & 1 and so so
qubit is this linear combination
of 0 & 1 what are the biggest challenges
towards building a quantum computer
today we have several challenges in
building a quantum computer so one is
the noise problem that quantum computers
need to be isolated often in very cold
environments protecting them from noise
at a mathematical level is the challenge
but we have some amazing codes we can
use to help protect against that so so
achieving scalability and
fault-tolerance with air quantum error
correction seems very feasible now but
the technologies have to reach a certain
what we call threshold or fidelity of
the gates the gates have to be at least
have at least a certain reliability in
order for the error correction to
actually work and what's what's exciting
right now is that in the last year there
have been several demonstrations that
the gates now have reached the
Fidelity's necessary for error
correction to work so so we're starting
to overcome that hurdle but now we have
to scale out so we hear about qubits we
hear quantum computers you know that
there are qubits that exist but we're
talking you know tens of qubits I think
maybe the maximum currently is around 14
qubits have been shown you know in one
system and I think that was an ion trap
system in superconducting qubits we have
I believe right now maybe five around
five is the largest and now they're
working to getting nine to act
coherently together to apply gates to
them to show you know a small
computation and in fact they want to
show a small error correction
demonstration with just this money so so
one of the hurdles right now is now
scaling up these systems to many qubits
because if we want to run a problem we
want to compute on a quantum computer we
need you know hundreds thousands ten
thousand cubits acting together and with
quantum error correction if you use a
system for example with superconducting
qubits now you're looking at you need
10,000 qubits to do
maybe you know a 10-10 cubit algorithm
because I need that overhead for air
correction we hope that in the system we
look at topological qubits we hope that
that scaling will be will have less
overhead that maybe we can get get away
with fewer you know qubits needed for
the error correction process but scaling
out to a hundred qubits hasn't been done
yet
so the scaling out is a challenge and
then we need to control the system so
keep it a quantum computer doesn't just
work on its own it needs a classical
computer to control it and that's a
really interesting non-trivial problem
building the classical computer that
controls the quantum computer you know
we have a quantum computer sitting down
in the cold we need to run
superconducting lines through a fridge
we may need to take care of the heat
dissipation that might occur
you know we're controlling thousands of
qubits at a cold temperature that's a
lot of multiplexing and communication we
have to look at the latency and the
speed that's going to you know set our
clock speed of our quantum computer and
all of that that that's going to be a
you know fun problem to look at as we
scale out the number of qubits so just
controlling them and being able to read
out in quantum error correction
measurement is actually part of the
process we measure out to see have
errors occurred so we're not looking at
the logical state but we look to see if
errors occurred and that all needs to be
fed back up to the classical computer in
a fast enough cycle that we can continue
correct the errors continue with our
algorithms so I think the scaling
problem even on the classical
electronics side we've never run
classical chips at 4 Kelvin when I think
of a computer I think of a pretty much a
single device that's in one area this
quantum entanglement allow a quantum
computer to exist in multiple places
around the world so in terms of quantum
entanglement we'd first take advantage
of that at just a single quantum chip
level we have to have entanglement to
achieve you know these speed ups that we
look at for quantum algorithms and to
get the kind of
exponential increase in terms of kind of
this massive parallelism that we take
advantage of in a quantum computer with
with qubits in superposition and then
entangled across the system now it's
true you know in for example quantum
teleportation we we can take you know we
can take a qubit interact or two qubits
I'm sorry you know to do some quantum
gates on them take one across to the
edge of the universe and then I act on
you know I give one to you and you go to
the edge I stay here and then I do
something to my qubit it simultaneously
does something to yours so that that's
the magic of entanglement like
instantaneous Morse code it's
instantaneous now there's there's some
caches because I have to send you some
information classically so I'm limited
by the speed of light and how fast I can
send that classical information to you
but the quantum process actually
occurred instantaneously now in terms of
using that for connecting quantum
computers around the world you know
possibly but right now we think of using
quantum entanglement more for
communication secure communication you
know less thinking about networked
quantum computers at this point because
we need to just master the entanglement
on a single quantum computer level but
it is used for quantum key distribution
you know for secure communication and
those processes and systems exist you
can buy quantum key devices now and send
information securely from two mountains
you know between mountains that's been
demonstrated in terms of using it for a
network potentially yeah you know most
most the time right now we think of
maybe using a photonic qubit to do
commute to build quantum networks
between quantum computers and that's
that's being developed right now and
that does use entanglement channels
what's unique about microsoft's approach
to quantum computing compared to what
others are doing in the field so here at
microsoft's we we have a unique approach
in how we're set up in terms of tackling
the challenges of quantum computing and
we have a group at Microsoft Research in
Redmond we have the quantum
architectures in a computation group
which focuses on the computer science
problems and Santa Barbara we have
station Q which focuses more on the
theoretical physics problems and then we
also work with experimental experimental
lists around the world university
professors who actually then try to
experiment and build these qubits and so
we have a unique setup in that we were
talking to physicists mathematicians
computer scientists and then we also
have a unique approach behind that which
is the topological qubits and
topological qubits were developed I'd
say in the last 10-15 years and Michael
Friedman was one of the primary drivers
of that research and what they found is
that by taking advantage of things
something called topology the topology
of a system that if you stretch things
apart you know the topology is actually
isn't changing and so if you take
advantage of topology it can offer some
natural what we call Hardware protection
against noise in conventional what I
call conventional qubits meaning not
topological qubits so superconducting
qubits ion traps at qubits of that sort
of that nature they need they need a lot
of software error correction to protect
against errors because the information
is stored just in the spin or just in
the state of this atom if that Adam gets
perturbed or a noise process occurs on
that atom you've lost your information
but in the topological qubits now it's
spread across some topology the
information so my information is
actually stored non locally which means
in storing maybe the information in to
distant or across a chain across a whole
lattice or in our case we we talk about
what are called my Ronna my Ronda's zero
modes which occur on the ends of a nano
wire so the information is stored across
this nano wire and it's harder to
perturb this system
just causing an error on one side will
actually not cause this cubit to
decohere and so this topological
property is key behind what we call
topological qubits and the systems we're
looking at so it's a very unique
approach in the hope is that this would
then allow us to use far fewer resources
to do a full quantum algorithm than say
conventional qubits will need less
overhead for quantum error correction
that's the hope are the programming
languages that exist today sufficient
for quantum computing or do we need to
rethink the way that we interface with
computers right
so our existing programming languages
don't have a notion of qubit and they
don't in a quantum programming language
we really want to protect or prevent the
programmer from doing things that aren't
allowed by quantum mechanics and quantum
computation you can't clone you can't
just copy you know it as as a classical
programmer would copy arrays will copy a
variable we're copying all the time
we cannot it's not allowed in quantum
mechanics there's a no cloning principle
and so we'd like the programming
language for example to prevent things
like cloning from happening you also
need to make sure that things are
unitary that it's it maintains the
reversibility and so so you want the
programming language to automatically
know the restrictions you have on the
kind of mathematical model or the
principles of quantum mechanics so so
we've actually developed in in my group
we've been developing a whole software
architecture that includes a
domain-specific language in fact that's
embedded in F sharp which was also
developed at Microsoft Research and
there it's nice to have a functional
language for quantum computing because
everything is really thought about in
terms of in terms of functions unit Ares
acting on state
and so then we can represent all of
these as functions and subroutines that
we can call you know within a quantum
circuit and and our our embedded
language tries to encode some of these
principles like for example no cloning
or reversibility and and how we hope
restricts the user from doing things
that are illegal in quantum mechanics
tell me about liquid so liquid is
something we've been developing in quark
in our group here that is a full
software architecture for quantum
computing so we think of compilers in
classical computing taking a high-level
algorithm all the way down to the the
target representation right down to the
hardware code same thing in quantum
computers we need to take a high-level
quantum algorithm and we need to
translate it compile it into code that
can run on a quantum device and so
liquid is this complete compiler this
complete system a software architecture
for this it includes the high-level
language that you can program your
quantum circuit that represents your
language your quantum algorithm in at
the highest level it will then translate
that to quantum circuits that operate
over a certain set of gates for example
your device might be limited in terms of
what gates that it can perform and so
you need to take something that was very
that was more general and actually now
map it to something more specific to
your device so liquid performs those
processes then it also performs
optimizations on that so we want to we
want to reduce the number of gates for
example in the circuit we actually want
to reduce one gate in particular that
tends to be more expensive due to things
we have to do for error correction and
other other operations so so what we do
there is then try to minimize the
occurrence of that gate by replacing the
circuit in different ways such that it's
still mathematically equivalent still
producing the same answer so liquid does
this series of compiler steps of
translation optimization
then it also has nice things like
rendering if I want to you know as a
quantum programmer we want to check our
circuits we want to try new ideas we
want to play with what what can we do
with quantum algorithms what new
problems can we attack with a quantum
computer we'll try different circuit
designs and liquid allows us to play
with this so in in present day we have
simulators where we can simulate these
quantum circuits and so liquid also
includes as a possible back-end a
variety of simulators depending on the
problem you're looking at but in terms
of Universal simulator I want to
simulate any quantum circuit I program
we can actually now simulate up to 31
qubits on your laptop 32 gigs of ram
this is actually state of the art 31
might not sound large but if you try to
simulate two hundred qubits you need
something like 10 to the 60 classical
bits so that's a huge system so 31
qubits on your laptop is we're very
excited about simulating that many and
you can do a lot of nice small problems
with 31 qubits so liquid also includes
these backends visualization tools
rendering tools to look at the quantum
circuit and debug visually things of
that sort
so it's a complete compiler system
complete software architecture for
quantum computing so I take it Microsoft
doesn't have a quantum computer today no
we don't have a quantum computer today
do we have a sense of how long it'll be
before this is something that'll be
widely adopted or able to be used
widespread right so our our interest is
really in advancing the state of quantum
computing from the theory side from you
know the experiment side we'd like to
see a topological qubit in the next few
years in terms of the scale and
timeframe of quantum computing more
generally we have for conventional
qubits you know we have maybe 10 in
order of 10 cubits currently and scaling
that out will take time and I think you
know in in
it's hard to name state an exact
timeframe but I I'm hopeful that say in
ten years we could do something that we
cannot perform on a classical computer
we could do that on account on a very
small quantum computer so say a hundred
qubits you know for a complete large
scalable quantum computer talking tens
of thousands or hundreds of thousands of
qubits you know that's definitely
further down the road but I hope in the
next say ten years we can do something
we can't do on a classical computer what
are some of the problems what's what's
possible with a quantum computer so
studying physical systems it's really
interesting for a quantum computer and
there we have examples where we can get
exponential speed-up applications of
that are in the area for example finding
catalysts understanding reaction
pathways that's useful for fertilizer
production so we actually use a large
amount of energy say 2% of the world's
energy usage goes to fertilizer
artificial fertilizer production and
there it's because the temperatures
required that atmospheric pressure
required is so high in order to convert
nitrogen to ammonia that process they've
been studying chemists have been looking
at for a long time to find a catalyst to
reduce the amount of energy required to
to perform that process a quantum
computer would allow us to search for a
catalyst that would allow a you know two
which would reduce the energy required
for that process and that could that
could be revolutionary in terms of you
know the world food production so that's
that's one example where the simulation
of physical systems really can make a
difference and quantum computers could
potentially help what does quantum
computing mean to machine learning
quantum computing for machine learning
is something we're actively looking at
right now it's it's just starting to be
studied for in quantum computing what we
think is possible so we know quantum
computers give exponential speed ups for
problems for example Shor's algorithm
simulation of physical systems
the question is can we get exponential
speed ups for areas of problems in you
know big data learning problems data
analysis problems machine learning and
there we're still actively looking we
have some new results showing that we
can get speed ups quadratic speed ups in
problems like nearest neighbor
classifications so various
classification problems and what I like
to think in terms of machine learning
and quantum computing is what questions
can we ask now that we have a quantum
computer that are different from the
questions we ask in machine learning
traditionally so now we have access to
new probability distributions may be new
inference techniques what does that give
us for machine learning it could give us
much better models of users systems you
know whatever we're studying so what I
think is really exciting in the area of
machine learning and quantum computing
is the ability to ask these new
questions not necessarily just look for
these speed ups speed ups might not be
as important as being able to ask a new
question so this could really give a
huge shift in what we can do with
machine learning that's an area we're
really excited about
you